Let me break it down the first two
verses. Now it came to pass after these
things that God tested Abraham and said
to him,"Abraham, and he said,"Here I
am." Then he said, "Take now your son,
your only son, Isaac, whom you love, and
go to the land of Moriah,
land of Moriah, and offer him there as a
burnt offering on one of the mountains
which I shall tell you." So let's unpack
it. Please, Holy Spirit, illuminate me
to plunge the depth and bring out all
the meat by your power and to articulate
these facts clearly without error so we
can all fall more passionate love with
the Lord Jesus Christ. Please, Holy
Spirit, to not forget any point. Okay,
we're going to go through this and we're
going to end it with this.
Number one,
note God is telling Abraham to do what
the gods and goddesses of the pagans
required of them. It is a common
practice and it was a common practice
back then that the gods and goddesses of
the pagans, the Gentiles,
required of them sacrifices, not just
animals, but even human sacrifices. Baal
required human sacrifice. The god Malik
required human sacrifice. In in fact,
Malik required child sacrifice. Even to
this day, as we speak in India, you have
the cult of Khali. Those of you are
Indians, you can confirm this. Khali is
a wicked demon goddess who requires
human sacrifices to be appeased. In
fact, in the film film Apocalyptto, it
accurately captures
the barbarity and I believe it was the
Aztecs, right? I think it's not about
the Aztecs. I keep forgetting which
particular
[clears throat] group of sacrificing
humans, cutting them open, taking their
heart out as a sacrifice to the son god
where the priest would eat the heart and
then would throw the body so that the
devities would then devour the body.
Right, sir? You're back early. What
happened?
>> Yep. You with me there?
the Mayans. All right. Now, one says
Aztecs, the other says Mayans. Whoever
it is, you get it. Why would then God
have Abraham
offer his son Isaac as a sacrifice?
When God is not like the pagan gods and
goddesses because the gods and goddesses
of the nations are demons, are devils.
the the gods and goddesses worshiped by
the peoples according to the Bible are
demons, Satan and evil spirits,
deceiving them, masquerading as gods and
goddesses. And then those same
fallen spirit creatures, rebellious
spirit creatures, fallen angels, Satan
and his army are now appearing as
aliens. Which is why even people today
call these gods and goddesses ancient
aliens. And there's even a series on the
History Channel called ancient aliens
where so-called experts on the ancient
mythologies and pagan religions and on
aliens say that
those gods and goddesses are the aliens
that are appearing today. Are you seeing
the connection today?
Satan and demons are appearing as aliens
and people are making the connection
with the aliens today with the gods and
goddesses of the past saying, "Oh, so
what they called gods and goddesses are
actually these aliens that are appearing
today, but to them they thought they
were gods and goddesses."
Same lie of Satan. Nothing new under the
sun but re being repackaged because
Satan will appear and demons will appear
in any way you want them to appear if
that will result in them misleading you
to damn you and destroy you and keeping
you away from the true God.
Right?
You hear me there?
Everyone got it?
Nothing new under the sun.
History repeats itself because it's the
same wicked satanic lie over and over
again just packaged differently.
[clears throat]
Okay, so these aliens are those gods and
goddesses of the nations. They're not
extraterrestrials. They are demons. It's
Satan and demons, evil spirits who can
appear in any shape and form you want
them pierced. So they can appear as
Zeus. They can appear as Thor. They can
appear as Khali. You name it. They don't
care as long as they keep you away from
the true God. But praise the true God
for the Bible cuz the Bible is God's
wisdom that
exposes the schemes of the kingdom of
darkness so that we're not deceived.
Know the Bible. Know the book and you
can't be deceived.
All right. You need attention sir. Okay.
So now coming back to the issue.
Why would God mimic the gods and
goddesses
of the pagans and requiring child
sacrifice? Because Isaac was a human, a
child, when that would give Abraham the
impression that my God is no different
than these gods and goddesses because he
too requires child sacrifice. This is
why Abraham did not hesitate by the way
because Abraham was exposed to the
paganism
of the people from or of Calaldia as
well as the Canaanites and he knew it
was a given among these pagans part of
their custom to offer human sacrifice
particularly child sacrifice to their
gods and goddesses which is why he goes
ahead and does it because he's now
thinking okay then I guess God is no
different than them he too requires
child sacrifice
So why would God do that? Well, let me
tell you why. From reading the text and
meditating on it, two facts. Number one,
God
was doing this to show would Abraham be
willing to do as much for the true God
as the pagans do for their false gods
and goddesses. In other words, Abraham,
do you love me as much as these pagans
do? And would you be willing to kill
your son for me if I required of you
much like the pagans do for gods and
goddesses who use them and abuse them
and manipulate them and oppress them?
That's number one.
Okay? It's to see not so much from God's
perspective, but from our perspective.
Do we does Abraham love the true God
more than Muslims love Allah and
Muhammad more than Hindus love their
gods and goddesses? Because these people
are willing themselves up
for their gods and goddesses. Do we love
our God just as much, if not more so,
than they do? And if so, are we willing
to do everything our God requires? Even
being willing to give everything up and
be killed for him because we cannot kill
those who don't accept Christ. We can
defend our lives, protect ourselves from
being killed, but we can't murder people
who don't accept Christ. But that's the
point. The lesson here is, do you
Christian love Jesus Christ more than
Muslims love Muhammad? Do you Christians
love Aba Father more than Muslims love
Allah? If so, are you more zealous than
the Muslims are to obey Christ and be
holy and pure and worship him
ceaselessly like Muslims do who pray
five times a day and fast an entire
month and willing to give up part of
their financial earnings for the cause
of Allah. See, this is the point you're
supposed to see. That's point number
one.
So Abraham,
do you love me as much as the pagans
love their gods and goddesses? If so,
are you willing to your son for me like
their sons for their gods and goddesses
like the Canaanites offer human child
sacrifice to the god Malik? And Google
it, you'll see archaeology has confirmed
that you you'll find a statue of Malik
with outstretched arms. And the priest
and priest of Malik would then heat up
the arms till they became scorching hot
and take the baby and put them on the
arms. So they would
as a sacrifice to Malik. I can't move on
if you're not getting it's a class
session for you. And the second fact
that God wants Abraham to learn and he's
going to learn it later on. Fact number
two, Abraham, I'm not like these gods
because unlike them, I don't demand
human sacrifice. So
first of all, do you love me
more than these pagans love their gods?
And are you willing to sacrifice your
son like they sacrifice their children,
their sons and daughters to their gods
and goddesses? And then secondly,
your willingness to do so shows that you
do love me more than they love their
gods. But I'm not a god like them. There
is no god like me. No god can compare to
me. And therefore, I'm not a god who
requires of you or anyone else to
sacrifice their children to me cuz I
hate human sacrifice. Meaning
innocent human lives is the shedding of
innocent blood and God hates it.
So these are the two facts Abraham is
learning.
Are you with me there? These are the two
facts that Abraham is learning.
Before I move on, Jeremiah 32:25,
Jeremiah 19:5. Let me read this for you.
Let me read these for you. Jeremiah
19:5 and 32:25.
Here you go. Let me read this. Look what
he says. Speaking of the Israelites
sacrificing to Baal, to Molech. Jeremiah
19:5, folks, New King James Version.
They have also built the high places of
Baal to burn their sons with fire for
burnt offerings to Ba, which I did not
command or speak, nor did it come into
my mind.
Nor did it come into my mind.
Okay? Jeremiah 32:35, not 25, but 35.
You see the difference between the true
God. The true God says, "I didn't even
think about such a thing. Nor would I
even
come up with a command requiring of you
to burn your children as a sacrifice to
me like Baal requires." Let me read it
again. Jeremiah 19:5
and Jeremiah 32:35, not 25. Okay. They
have also built the high places of Baal
to burn their sons with fire for burnt
offerings to Baal, which I did not
command or speak, nor did it come into
my mind. Jeremiah 32:35. And this is
where we get the word geah or gein, the
valley of Hanam. Jeremiah 32:35.
Remember these passages, folks.
Remember these passages, okay?
And they built the high places of Baal
which are in the valley of the son of
Hinam. The valley of the son of Hinam.
That's where you get ginam gah from. The
valley of the son of Ham to cause their
sons and their daughters to pass through
the fire to male which I did not command
them nor did it come into my mind that
they should do this abomination, this
wicked evil thing to cause Judah to sin.
So Jeremiah 19:5, Jeremiah 32:35 says,
"Our God is unlike the gods and
goddesses of the nations. Our God would
never dare command his servants to
their innocent children, sons and
daughters, as a sacrifice to appease
him." Are you with me there? Thank you.
Eyes like the summer. Sam, you have no
idea how much of a blessing are. Thank
you, brother. May I always be humble and
teachable and never get puffed up. And
pray that I remain faithful and holy in
love with the Lord Jesus Christ and
never shame Jesus but love him, live for
him, and die for him. Because without
the spirit, I'm weak. Without the
spirit, I can do worse than Robbie
Zachcharitas. May God save me from that
and not give me what I deserve. But is
that clear? So the point of the test was
to teach Abraham and us by extension two
things. Do you love God just as much? In
fact, more so than the pagans love their
gods and goddesses than Muslims love
Allah and Muhammad. If so, are you
willing to be as zealous as they are,
and more so to do all you can to honor
God with your life, with your time and
finances, and be willing to give it all
up and die for him? Oh, look what he
says. Amen. I have struggled with this
since I was an Orthodox Jew. Well, it's
a blessing that the father, son, lord
Jesus, holy spirit would use me to bless
you, a former orthodox Jew to understand
why God did this. So, it's now making
sense. What a blessing. Thank you, man.
You blessed me. A former Orthodox Jew
saying he had a hard time with Genesis
22. And finally, a slave of the triune
God, a slave of the father, a slave of
the Lord Jesus, a slave of the Holy
Spirit. And that's my boast. I'm the
slave of God, though I'm unworthy to be
a slave, would be used to help you
understand the issue.
Everyone got it?